[Musique]
mais comment
ses fils en tout complètement folle de
toi tu as dit elles sont folles et ça
n'a rien à voir avec moi je t'aime tu
réponds quoi pourquoi ils nous envient
temps ça né orphelin est on obligé de
parcourir le monde comme des gitans on
aider les jambes pour ces enfants n'a
vaincu la reine des neiges et sauver le
monde des légendes tu sérieuse j'ai
plutôt l'impression d'être une bête de
foire ou un singe qui jouent des
symboles les élèves seront là d'une
seconde à les autres maintenant vous
pourrez commencer dans cinq petites
minutes
ces enfants sont notre nouvelle raison
de vivre ils ont besoin de personne ne
remplacera jamais nos parents guerdat
tiens c'est pour toi voulait offrir ce
cadeau
c'est une peinture que j'ai fait pour
toi waouh kayes
c'est toi qui fais ça merci beaucoup
elle est magnifique c'est incroyable
mais tu étais si petit la dernière fois
que tu as vu papa et maman comment tu
t'es souvenu de leur visage il m'arrive
de les voir souvent dans mon sommeil
arts kai
merci beaucoup
on l'appelle la pierre aux souhaits si
une personne la trouve effet un voeu
il se réalisera la pierre aux soins ça
fait longtemps maintenant que je la
cherche
on se connaît par coeur in his ça les
esprits de la reine des neiges et du roi
du feu sont sortis de la pierre aux
souhaits et nous ont possédé rolland et
moi on n'est plus des amateurs
on est des pros ouais si on les retrouve
pas bientôt c'est le monde tout entier
qu'il sera dévorée par les flammes
y aller tout seul
l'otan devrait peut-être attachez vos
ceintures
[Applaudissements]
voilà mon rien
à nous
et commencer
ve
[Musique]